[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP nous sommes
ensemble pendant une heure autour d'un
plat d'un dessert d'un invité pour
parler alimentation agriculture écologie
mais aussi politique et cette semaine
nous recevons Josiane Corneloup bonjour
bonjour et bienvenue avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte bonjour Josiane Corneloup vous
êtes député les républicains de
Saône-et-Loire depuis 2017 pharmacienne
de profession vous avez exercé à
Saint-Bonnet de Jouy votre ville natale
vous vous êtes engagé tôt en politique
d'abord au conseil municipal des 86 puis
vous devenez maire de Saint-Bonnet de
jouy-en 2014 c'est un petit village
d'appel 30 km2 qui compte 762 habitants
il est situé dans la communauté de
communes du Grand charolais dont vous
avez été vice-présidente alors quand on
entend grand charolais évidemment on se
dit que la Charolaise n'est pas très
loin alors peut-être une indication pour
le menu du jour Jean-Pierre bienvenue
Brigitte au menu un bœuf Bourguignon
parti avec de la viande de charolaise et
en dessert CR tomber au Grand Marnier
dans le dessous des plats le succès des
compléments alimentaires chez les
Français alors sont-ils efficaces ou y
a-t-il un effet placebo l'enquête de
Pierre Michael Carniel dans les pieds
dans plat Garou comment à la fois
défendre l'espèce en liberté et les
éleveurs de brebis casse-tête à suivre
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
alors Josiane Corneloup rien que votre
nom nous indique clairement ce que vous
êtes et ce que vous aimez manger c'est
bien simple un corps-neu d'un point de
vue étymologique brigitte c'est celui ou
celle qui cornes au loups c'est à dire
qui sonne au corps bref qui mène la
chasse aux loups ce qui en plus bien
votre cas c'est incroyable mais vrai on
le verra plus tard alors on aurait pu
aussi penser que vous préférez un loup
mort plutôt qu'en liberté donc on allait
donc se régaler d'un loup en daube
pourquoi pas et oui le loup gris le
saviez-vous est apprécié des gourmets
viande de caractère paraît-il le service
des sauvages à la chair ferme et maigre
et quand elle est sublimée par une
marinade au vin rouge et au cognac c'est
top paraît-il mais hélas non pas de loup
dans notre assiette mais du boeuf
bourguignon bien de chez vous charolais
avec ses belles cornes rondes et
blanches mais que je suis bête je réduis
penser car dans corps de loup il y a
aussi le mot corne comme un message
subliminal pour nous fléchir vers la
bête et votre penchon peut être viandard
et Chauvin de l'élu de Saône-et-Loire
que vous êtes est-ce que je me trompe je
viens de loups alors viandard oui
j'apprécie la viande bien évidemment en
plein cœur de la race charolaise
chauvant non il y a d'autres d'autres
races effectivement j'ai tendance à
penser que la race charolaise et la
meilleure voilà évidemment
en tout cas c'est vrai que j'ai choisi
ce bubble bourguignon parce que je suis
en plein coeur du Charolais et nous
avions nous avons une viande
d'excellence avec un savoir-faire tout à
fait remarquable avec des éleveurs qui
œuvrent de manière incroyable dans
l'assiette nous avons des terroirs aussi
qui sont extrêmement propices et bien
évidemment déguster cette viande de
qualité qui sublime les papilles est un
vrai bonheur pour moi donc vous vous
dites leur rendre hommage plus que
finalement déguster un bœuf Bourguignon
parce que c'est aussi une spécialité
locale bien sûr et c'est un plat très
apprécié des français nous en parlions
je crois que ce plat est dans le top 10
des Français donc ça dépasse largement
le Charolais je crois que le bœuf
Bourguignon c'est aussi la convivialité
vous ne faites pas un bœuf Bourguignon
lorsque vous êtes seul donc il y a la
notion de partage de convivialité autour
de ce plat et si vous faites souvent par
exemple chez vous oui si j'ai du temps
je fais je cuisine on en parlera
peut-être assez peu le but de l'émission
parce que effectivement mon activité par
le notaire fait que j'ai peu de temps
mais si j'ai du temps oui j'adore
cuisiner mais par plaisir ou pas
obligation un plaisir vous êtes la reine
des fourneaux qu'est-ce que vous faites
de tout je cuisine français comme le
Bourguignon et j'aime beaucoup les plats
traditionnels le poulet de braise j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup ces repas ces
plats qui se partagent ces plats uniques
la blanquette la blanquette exactement
et j'adore toute la cuisine qui a du
caractère ça veut dire que j'aime la
cuisine qui a du goût elle est un peu
relevé alors est-ce que vous mettez
justement pour
du laurier je mets des alcools oui des
vins bah là il y a du vin en
l'occurrence dans ce bourguignon du
bourgogne j'imagine pour être chaud en
général ça se fait que du côtes de nuit
du Côte de Beaune on va le goûter pour
voir si euh il est certainement pas
aussi bon que le vôtre pourquoi parce
que j'imagine que vous avez une recette
secrète que vous allez nous livrer dans
quelques-uns et puis en plus le fait de
mijoter ces viandes voyez-vous de les je
trouve qu'elles sont sublimes
lorsqu'elles sont mijotées petit à petit
au niveau c'est vrai que c'est meilleur
le lendemain presque quand c'est oui et
que c'est je trouve que moi j'aime
beaucoup ces viandes cuisiner justement
mijoter les petits lardons les petites
carottes les petits oignons tout ça
j'avais une astuce pour réussir un bon
bœuf bourguignon vous avez il y a un peu
la pâte corneloupe
est un grand mot en tout cas oui moi
j'aime beaucoup bien faire rissoler les
morceaux déjà dans un premier temps et
puis ensuite ajouter le vent et faire
cuire tout un très très basse
température et très longtemps et puis
ajouter au dernier moment les petites
carottes les petits oignons
les aromates pour trouver si vous voulez
de la tendreté et du goût et que les
légumes ne soient pas trop cuits
et pour la sauce comment vous faites
pour la faire un peu épaissir c'est
parce que vous le lorsque vous faites
sauter les morceaux vous mettez vous
liés avec un petit peu de farine oui
voilà farine maïzena et puis ça permet
de prendre un peu voilà ça permet ça
peut faire un peu non mais ça permet
d'avoir une sauce un petit peu liée et
un petit peu de chocolat parce que il me
semble que vous nous aviez dit ça dans
une des précédentes recettes
effectivement c'est ça peut donner un
peu de lion et un peu de onctuosité
alors déguster ce ce très bon
bourguignon pendant ce temps là
Jean-Pierre trois choses à savoir sur la
Charolaise oui sur cette race charolaise
elle se distingue cette vache par sa
robe de couleur blanche ou crème je
parle sous le contrôle de Josiane
Corneloup ses yeux proéminents et sa
queue orné d'une petite touffe de crin
fin un mâle peut peser jusqu'à 7 tonnes
ça fait une belle bête hein
c'est très appréciée des éleveurs pour
son comportement docile ça ne savais pas
la Charolaise et très sympa à vivre ça
facilité d'adaptation au système de
production extensif intensif tout lui va
cette vache charolaise elle peut être
élevée à l'herbe et ça c'est bien et une
femme met bas un veau une fois par an et
peut donner jusqu'à 7 litres de lait par
jour enfin dans l'assiette la viande
charolaise protégée par une AOC est très
appréciée par ce qui aiment l'avion des
viandes comme on dit pour son moelleux
ça saveur grâce à son taux de matière
grasse très bas combien de matières
grasses Brigitte à votre avis aucune
idée 5% comme la volaille comme la voilà
donc on peut manger de la viande rouge
ça devient rouge c'est pas très gras les
chefs préconisent une cuisson lente à
feu doux
il faut privilégier les boeufs qui ont 3
ans et c'est idéal pour des plats en
sauce comme ce bœuf bourguignon alors
aucune erreur vous avez vu juste est-ce
que ça vous plaît est-ce que vous le
trouvez bon excellent et aussi bon que
le vôtre dites-nous allez franchement un
peu plus tendre le mien peut-être mais
parce qu'il cuit plus longtemps
peut-être qu'il a cuit plus rapidement
voilà c'est ça
alors du coup vous mangez beaucoup de
viande vous faites attention parce qu'on
dit maintenant attention pour la santé
faut pas manger trop de viande et puis
les vaches aussi produisent des gaz à
effet de serre donc pour la planète
est-ce que vous avez réduit un peu votre
consommation de viande vous qui êtes
viande art non non moi je suis toujours
dans une consommation mesurée et je ne
rejoins absolument pas ceux qui pensent
que la viande est mauvaise à la santé
je pense vraiment
d'équilibre voilà effectivement si vous
mangez un kilo de viande par jour je
pense que vous allez avoir très vite des
problèmes mais à partir du moment où
vous avez une alimentation équilibrée et
c'est pour la viande comme pour d'autres
aliments mais vous vous en mangez autant
qu'avant parce qu'on dit aujourd'hui que
effectivement la consommation de viande
on le voit baisse vous en mangez tous
les jours par exemple ou viande ou
poisson oui toujours ah oui viens de
façon toujours pas de de produits
végétaux ou de non non pas de complément
ouais et comment les éleveurs qui sont
très attachés à leurs bêtes alors
terroir à leur viande réagissent face à
ce mouvement anti-viant de manger moins
de viande
où est-ce qu'il s changent un peu leur
paradigme ils se disent ben produisons
plus de la meilleure viande parce que
les Français en mangent moins souvent
comment réagissent-ils non je crois
qu'ils sont ils sont inquiets et on a vu
en plus tous les épisodes d'agribashing
et moi je vais essayer de les défendre
au maximum et de condamner ses actions
parce que je pense que nous avons
aujourd'hui une viande de grande qualité
et on en parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure nous voyons aujourd'hui des
viandes qui arrivent du Brésil puisque
l'importation aujourd'hui est très
importante
avec des accords du Mercosur et du CETA
etc avec des viandes qui ne répondent
absolument pas à nos cahiers des charges
en termes en termes de produits utilisés
pour pour cet élevage poulet aux
hormones
et je trouve que c'est vraiment dommage
si vous voulez de ne pas conforter ces
productions de qualité et chez nous ce
sont des productions de très grande
qualité vous disiez que nous avions une
AOC nous avons également désormais une
AOP de Charolles c'est une viande qui
est produite sur un territoire très
restreint c'est une viande qui est née
sur place qui a grandi sur place qui a
été engraissée sur place uniquement avec
de l'herbe parfois si ça ne suffit pas
avec quelques céréales de la luzerne
locale vous le disiez c'est une viande
qui a du goût c'est une viande qui est
persillée
c'est une viande au niveau de la
traçabilité qui est parfaite qu'elle est
chère puisqu'elle est précieuse et donc
du coup certains Français ne peuvent pas
la consommer et se détournent vraiment
tous les jours
de manger aussi que du filet voyez-vous
qui est effectivement un coup beaucoup
plus vous mangez un Bourguignon c'est
beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup plus
accessible en termes de prix nobles et
mes meilleurs marchés
mais vous avez dans la dans le bœuf un
panel de choix de morceaux qui
permettent je pense de répondre à tous
les budgets alors vous nous disiez
viande et poisson parce que vous êtes en
bord de Saône aussi il y a des pleins de
poissons d'eau douce finalement est-ce
que vous vous en consommez aussi
beaucoup est-ce-que c'est pas pas tout à
fait la même cuisine J'aime beaucoup la
viande j'aime beaucoup le poisson
également et je cuisine également de
poisson oui bien sûr en sauce comme ça
on est en sauce
avec du vin blanc j'imagine exactement
bougie parler de la somme mais vous
mangez les poissons de la
pourquoi pas il y a un la pushouse ça
vous dit quelque chose ou pas c'est une
spécialité de chez vous je suis tombé
là-dessus spécialité de Saône-et-Loire
mélange de poisson de rivière au vin
blanc ça doit être un peu ce que vous
préparez finalement oui voilà moi en
général je mets toujours des petits
champignons du vin blanc etc ouais c'est
comme ça dans la cuisine là vous nous
avez demandé plutôt du vin rouge du coup
pour aller avec ce avec ce plat domaine
roche des bancs c'est dans le Brionnais
c'est un bourgogne évidemment évidemment
j'allais dire pinot noir c'est c'est ces
pages là et on a une particularité c'est
qu'il est assez léger et fruitée il y a
des notes de fruits rouges et de et de
cerise pourquoi vous avez spécialement
choisi ce vin là
et bien d'abord parce que c'est un petit
clin d'oeil à ma circonscription
puisque en particulier au Brionnais
puisque il y avait
il y a quelques années de cela un vin
qui s'appelait le vin des fossiles il y
avait 4000 hectares sur un certain
nombre de communes Mailly grandes
oyé à manger etc
cette activité viticole c'était vraiment
une activité complémentaire à l'activité
agricole
et il produisait un vin de ferme enfin
assez brut en fait et en fait
un certain nombre de ces parcelles ont
été rachetées par un couple Monsieur et
Madame Hélin et Madame et champenoise
donc voilà et en fait ils ont eu une
grande ambition pour valoriser ce
terroir et pour redonner ses lettres
noblesse assez parcelles donc ils ont
fait énormément de travail ils ont
replanté des cèpes ils sont aujourd'hui
en culture bio il y a 8 hectares de
production
ils se sont entourés de personnes dotées
de compétences très spécifiques et
aujourd'hui et bien nous avons il
produisent donc ce vin rouge il
produisent également des vins blancs et
des pétillants
j'ai vu qu'il s'appelait l'effrontés
donc et qui sont aujourd'hui sur des
grandes tables des grandes tables chez
moi mais également des grandes tapes
parisiennes et j'ai voulu les encourager
en la Renaissance finalement d'interro
exactement qui est exactement qui à
l'époque fait avec 4000 hectares
effectivement avant le filet de 86 qui a
rasé tout ça et puis aujourd'hui c'est
un petit ouais c'est un petit domaine
ouais mais je trouve que c'est un petit
domaine qui a une grande ambition
puisque on voit qu'aujourd'hui il a déjà
acquis une vraie notoriété qui est déjà
sur des grandes tables de chef étoilé
donc je trouve que c'est un clin d'oeil
que je souhaitais leur faire pour leur
témoigner tout mon encouragement à
poursuivre puisque je crois qu'ils ont
aussi la volonté d'aller au-delà de ces
8 hectares de production et ça se marie
très bien aussi avec le plat j'ai tout
de même essayé de sortir le vin
je veux pas jouer les rabat-joie je
parlais de l'inquiétude des éleveurs de
viande face au mouvement anti-viande et
face au réchauffement climatique est-ce
que vos viticulteurs sont inquiets ce
qu'ils se disent un jour qui pourront
plus garder leur leurs appellations
parce qu'il faudra modifier les cépages
pour faire en sorte que ces vins
résistent à aux températures à la
sécheresse je crois que ça doit être une
question que nous devons tous nous poser
j'ai beaucoup de forêts également dans
ma circonscription c'est une véritable
inquiétude puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui
que nous avons des espèces qui qui
meurent du fait de la chaleur bien sûr
et je pense que les viticulteurs sont
dans la même dans la même considération
si vous voulez il faut il faut que nous
réfléchissions effectivement peut-être
changer les plantations peut-être
changer des cépages plus habituelles qui
sont plus résistants exactement et ça
nous impactera tous Demain c'est évident
et donc vous voyez ce terroir changé ou
pour l'instant il résiste finalement
face à ces éléments pour l'instant il
résiste encore même si je vous le dis au
niveau des forêts on voit des arbres qui
meurent qui deviennent tout rouge tout
marron et j'étais l'autre jour avec des
forestiers il y a des outils aujourd'hui
qui relève de l'intelligence
artificielle qui sont capables de vous
dire si dans 20 ans ou 25 ans si vous
plantez un arbre là est-ce qu'il a une
chance de survivre ou est-ce que vous
devez changer d'espèces donc il faut
changer les arbres il faut replanter
d'autres arbres qui sont susceptibles de
résister dans 30 ans 50 ans aujourd'hui
vous disiez ce que vous vous le voyez au
niveau de la vigne je ne le vois pas
vraiment en revanche au niveau de des
arbres plantés je le vois on commence à
planter des pins maritimes des Cèdres
c'était des arbres que nous voyons pas
chez nous on avait beaucoup plus de
Douglas alors on va voir si vous êtes
vraiment incollables c'est le quiz
alors Josiane Corneloup vous êtes expert
en loup mais êtes-vous incollable sur ce
poisson nommé loup seriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations le concernant son
vrai ou fausses alors ah vous avez même
un petit écran qui vous rappelle les
affirmations le loup de Méditerranée se
nomme bar quand il vit dans l'océan
Indien il y a un piège
je dirais que c'est faux parce qu'il se
nomme barre quand il loge dans l'océan
Atlantique
le loup fait partie des poissons de la
vraie bouillabaisse de Marseille la
vraie de vrai hein peu cher on dirait
que oui
Jacques pic chef de la vénérable Maison
Pic avec inventé en 1973 une recette
culte le loup au caviar d'Iran vrai ou
faux
et ce nom de loup à propos du poisson
toujours vient de son oeil perçant qui
ressemble à celui du canidé sauvage donc
du loup qui rôde chez vous vrai ou faux
oh faux c'est à cause de sa voracité
qu'on appelait ce poisson le loup bravo
dessus
vous êtes vraiment la spécialiste du
loup même si le marin alors maintenant
on va se rapprocher d'une autre de vos
spécialités puisque vous êtes
pharmacienne de profession certains
aliments sont un peu des médicaments
alors sauriez-vous nous dire pourquoi
ces aliments sont bons alors si on prend
l'artichaut est-ce que c'est bon pour
lutter contre les rhumes pour la
digestion pour la vésicule ou pour le
cœur la vésicule pour la vésicule
exactement
alors le citron est-ce que c'est bon du
coup pour lutter contre les rhumes pour
la digestion ou pour le cœur
le citron c'est pour les rhumes enfin
c'est riche en vitamine C comme les
aliens exactement
les macros donc est-ce que c'est bon
pour la digestion ou pour le cœur le
cœur le cœur les oméga 3
alors le pois chiche du coup bah la
digestion oui le pois chiche ça permet
d'être à digérer
[Rires]
vous avez
mes connaissances
alors vous savez qu'en politique le
repas occupe une large place et c'est
particulièrement autour d'un repas que
se font les deals et c'est souvent là
que ce nous les petites et les grandes
histoires c'est la brève de comptoir
alors je tienne corne Delon vous a
demandé de réfléchir à une anecdote
autour d'un souvenir en politique autour
d'un repas est-ce que vous avez une
histoire à nous raconter
alors c'est une histoire bien
particulière
c'est qu'en fait il y a peu de temps
j'ai été convié à une manifestation
[Rires]
même si effectivement on a quand même 2
milliards aujourd'hui de personnes qui
mangent des insectes l'Asie l'Afrique
c'est pas l'alimentation il y a beaucoup
de protéines et justement j'ai été
horrifiée de voir que la Commission
européenne avait autorisé la
commercialisation de poudre d'insectes
en particulier des grillons
pour intégrer tout ce qui était
boulangerie industriels les gâteaux les
pizzas etc enfin des tas de de recettes
uniquement pour nourrir les animaux
et en fait alors bien sûr vous il y a
des règles d'étiquetage donc ce sera
noté sur l'étiquetage sauf que à la
boulangerie on sent pas trop puis je ne
sais pas si vous regardez de façon très
détaillée tout ce qui est composition
des pâtisseries industrielles mais
souvent vous avez quand même un grand
nombre d'ingrédients et vous allez avoir
ces poudres d'insectes ce qui je trouve
est assez dramatique parce que déjà d'un
point de vue sanitaire il n'y a pas de
traçabilité
l'ancêtre disait que
[Musique]
il y a des recherches scientifiques qui
ont porté à peu près sur 10 insectes
alors qu'on sait que on a une un nombre
d'insectes extrêmement importants qui
vont être concernés et on a aucune
précision quand à leurs conditions
d'élevage aucune traçabilité donc je
trouve ça dommage et je trouve ça
d'autant plus dommage pour nos éleveurs
nos agriculteurs si vous voulez parce
que je trouve que c'est quelque part un
outrage qu'on leur fait si c'est la
seule façon que nous avons de pérenniser
l'agriculture et de développer un modèle
agricole demain
si c'est simplement de faire appel à de
la poudre d'insectes et bien je trouve
ça très décevant par rapport au
savoir-faire et à la qualité des
produits que nous avons aujourd'hui qui
émanent de notre agriculture française
vous nous dites que ce monde de demain
ou en Saône-et-Loire dans 50 ans les
éleveurs de charolais vont cultiver des
grillons ça vous n'en voulez pas non
c'est pourtant c'est peut-être ce qui va
arriver pour nourrir la planète est-ce
qu'il faudra pas en passer par là de
personnes il va falloir les nourrir mais
je trouve dommage qu'on ne mise pas
davantage sur une agriculture
traditionnelle qui je trouve pour notre
santé est une une garantie de bonne
santé et qui est une agriculture de
grande qualité
alors on va avancer dans cette émission
on va parler santé effectivement parce
que pour pallier un régime déséquilibré
certains font appel aux complément
alimentaire vous en tant que
pharmacienne vous savez de quoi on parle
c'est un marché florissant c'est le
dessous des plats
et oui le marché des compléments
alimentaires se porte bien même si
l'efficacité de ces produits n'est pas
toujours prouvé les pharmacies offrent
des dizaines de références pour
s'adapter à un large public une
entreprise lyonnaise a innover avec des
sprays à vaporiser directement dans la
bouche reportage pierre Michael Carniel
et Arnaud Paillard
pulvériser sous la langue du fenouil
pour une meilleure digestion ou du thym
pour renforcer son immunité et cette
entreprise de lyonnaise est la première
en France à lancer une gamme de
compléments alimentaires en spray les
principes actifs vont être absorbés
directement dans le plancher de la
bouche très rapidement ils vont arriver
dans le centre et rapidement ils vont
être efficaces et ils vont être très peu
dégradés c'est plus facile à prendre
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avaler une
gélule qui sont pas forcément adaptées à
la morphologie d'un enfant ou parfois
les personnes âgées ont tendance à faire
des fausses routes donc on trouve ça
très bien que il y a de l'innovation
c'est un petit peu dépoussiéré un marché
qui était parfois un petit peu stagnant
nutriments minéraux et vitamines se
déclinent sous de nouvelles formes nous
on n'est pas des bonbons on veut pas que
les gens piquent ça dans la télé c'est
quelque chose de pas qui enfin qui est
pas anodin quoi pas anodin dans un
secteur ou plus de 400 marques se
bousculent dans les rayons des
pharmacies en excluant ils ont mis à au
miel moi suggest c'est de la Remi à
également on voit qu'il y a une réelle
demande ça a été une réelle volonté de
d'augmenter énormément la gamme de
marché qu'on pouvait proposer à nos
patients parce que mine de rien même si
on est sur des choses naturelles il faut
quand même avoir en tête que chaque que
ce soit des plantes ou des molécules
chaque molécule va avoir une indication
particulière qu'il faut pas y prendre de
n'importe quelle façon du côté de UFC
Que Choisir on alerte sur les excès et
un contrôle de la répression des fraudes
qui a relevé des allégations comme
l'huile de concombre aide à soigner les
maladies psychiatriques la perception
qu'on les consommateurs des compléments
alimentaires qui est alimenté à la fois
parce que disent les influenceurs par le
marketing assez malins des fabricants
etc et qui va beaucoup jouer et qui va
et qui va booster un peu l'effet placebo
de ses compléments efficace ou pas le
marché du complément alimentaire
représenté plus de 2 milliards d'euros
en 2022
alors Josiane Corneloup vous vous avez
une pharmacie c'est votre fille qui la
tient maintenant de temps en temps vous
allez prêter ma forte s'il y a besoin
c'est ce que vous nous disiez est-ce que
vous proposez et vous vendez des
compléments alimentaires dans cette dans
cette pharmacie est-ce qu'on en trouve
et puis surtout est-ce que vous
constatez ce succès grandissant qu'on
remarque et dont on parlait dans ce
reportage bien sûr bien sûr que nous
vendons à la pharmacie des compléments
alimentaires
c'est certain qu'ils sont de plus en
plus consommés je crois que nous sommes
passés de 1 à 11%
et
vous parlez des officines
1% des Français qui ont consommé 11% qui
ont consommé maintenant encore volume de
consommation on est passé de 1 à 11 %
pour vous donner la progression qui est
quand même très importante beaucoup plus
la problématique c'est que vous parlez
des officines sauf qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une proportion de ces compléments
alimentaires qui est vendus sur Internet
très importante
où là vous n'avez aucun contrôle alors
certes les compléments alimentaires
comme leur nom l'indique ce sont des
compléments à une alimentation
normalement équilibrée variés
qui apporte des nutriments qui apportent
des vitamines des minéraux etc il faut
savoir que globalement si vous avez une
alimentation
diversifiée et équilibrée vous ne devez
pas être carencé les carences donc en
fait vous voulez naturels
sont assez rares elles sont
surtout liées à la vitamine D en fait
en fait en revanche vous avez des
populations pour lesquelles les
compléments alimentaires sont
indispensables ce sont par exemple des
personnes âgées ce sont des enfants ce
sont des femmes enceintes parce que là
justement il y a des besoins accrus ou
par exemple des sportifs qui vont
consommer énormément certains minéraux
certaines vitamines donc là les
compléments alimentaires sont
parfaitement judicieux toujours est-il
que j'ai envie de vous dire c'est
toujours la mesure et on l'évoquait pour
l'alimentation bien les compléments
alimentaires c'est la même chose c'est à
dire attention aux surdosage voilà c'est
à dire que si vous consommez
régulièrement des compléments
alimentaires mais de façon mesurée avec
des périodes qui ne soient pas trop
prolongées que vous respectez la
posologie et que vous vous assurez de
d'avoir recours un professionnel de
santé pour demander des conseils si vous
avez le souci de passer par un circuit
de distribution qui est contrôlé parce
que là aussi les compléments
alimentaires ce ne sont pas des
médicaments donc il n'y a pas
d'autorisation lui sur le marché voilà
donc sauf que c'est pas vraiment
contrôlé alors si sauf que normalement
ces produits doivent être doivent faire
l'objet d'une déclaration à la DGC ses
rêves la direction générale de la
concurrence et de la répression des
fraudes il y a des contrôles et voilà
non ce n'est pas la ce n'est pas la
pharmacie c'est la dgrève qui fait les
contrôles d'abord sur la liste des
produits qui peuvent ou ne peuvent pas
figurer dans ces compléments
alimentaires au même titre que tout
autre produit alimentaire sauf que ces
contrôles il faut qu'il soit réalisé et
si vous voulez le problème vous avez un
doute des ventes sur Internet c'est que
parfois voilà on n'est pas on n'est pas
absolument certain que ces contrôles
étaient réalisés il y a des arnaques sur
internet c'est à dire qu'il y a des
choses qu'on nous propose comme on le
voit en très bon pour le voir et puis il
faut se méfier il faut se méfier de tout
ce qui est mirifique émerveilleux au
niveau des effets si vous voulez mais il
est indéniable que vous prenez vous
évoquez l'artichaut on sait très bien
que l'artichaut justement le
propriétaire Que Choisir 10 c'était pas
c'était bidon mais visiblement ce
complément alimentaire avait eu le feu
vert non pour être commercialisé
c'était bidon
le problème c'est que nous ne savons pas
de d'où vient cette quel était circuit
de distribution effectivement tout ce
qui est vendu à l'officine
et contrôler vous vous savez que ce que
vous vendez est été efficace
et que tout est surdosage ça veut dire
que si vous respectez la posologie mais
vous avez aussi vous le disiez il y a un
engouement très fort pour les
compléments alimentaires parce que ça
rejoint aussi des médecines plus
naturelles à base de plantes etc etc et
le problème c'est que vous avez des
personnes comme ça n'est pas soumis à
prescription qui vont cumuler x
complément alimentaire donc si vous
voulez même au niveau des vitamines et
des minéraux vous avez des doses maximum
quotidiennes à respecter c'est quoi le
risque si on prend trop de vitamine C
trop de vitamines D c'est des surdosages
avec des effets indésirables
ça peut être ça peut être grave
effectivement si vous consommez beaucoup
trop de vitamines certaines vitamines
sont dangereuses avec des quads des
maladies graves à la clé non pas des
maladies graves mais des
dysfonctionnements et tout à fait pardon
est-ce que vous êtes prescriptrice par
exemple moi j'ai mal j'ai du mal à
dormir est-ce que vous préférez avoir
une petite molécules chimiques ou dit
bah non prenez ce complément alimentaire
à base de thym et vous allez dormir
alors le temps je suis pas sûr
je ne vais pas vous conseiller de passer
aux anxiolytiques d'emblée je vais
effectivement essayer de vous trouver
une solution un petit peu plus naturelle
parce qu'on sait qu'il y a une
dépendance aussi avec les anxiolytiques
et si c'est une première intention si
vous venez me voir en me disant voilà ça
fait une semaine je ne dors pas très
bien et je vais vous je vais vous
proposer quelque chose à base des
scolescia une plante qui soit un petit
peu sédatif de la valériane etc
peut-être de la mélatonine si c'est un
petit peu plus prononcé mais je ne vais
pas vous emmener immédiatement voir un
médecin si effectivement vous n'avez pas
d'efficacité avec ce premier conseil et
que vous ne dormez toujours pas ce qui
peut avoir d'autres effets perturbateurs
sur votre équilibre général je vais vous
envoyer voir un médecin pour
effectivement une prescription
anxiolytique
somnifère placebo sur ses produits là où
on se dit bon finalement je vais prendre
ça ça va m'aider à mieux dormir et puis
on dort mieux je ne pense pas du tout
non je ne pense pas du tout non je pense
qu'il y a une réelle efficace vraiment
quand c'est vraiment si c'est bien
prescrit à la bonne posologie si je
pense que oui vous avez une réelle
efficacité pour l'avoir testé très
nombreuses reprises je trouve aussi que
c'est un maquis parce qu'on dit
complément alimentaire moi je découvrais
un peu le terme dans la rédaction je
sais que beaucoup en parlait il y en a
qui en prennent etc mais il y a des
compléments alimentaires qui sont faits
à base d'aliments le fenouil artichaut
mais la mélatonine c'est pas fait à base
d'aliments
donc les compléments alimentaires
peuvent être d'un point de chimique ou
alors naturel et quels sont les
meilleurs naturelles ou chimiques ça ça
dépend de la sensibilité de chacun non
mais les meilleurs pour la santé
chimiques comme ça tous les jours
j'imagine si vous respectez la posologie
et que vous n'en prenez si vous avez
une perturbation de votre sommeil moi
j'ai fait énormément de conseils à
l'officine et j'étais passionné par le
Conseil parce que c'est là où vous
apportez une vraie plus-value et en fait
il faut toujours prendre en compte la
globalité de la personne si vous voulez
quelqu'un vient vous voir en vous disant
je ne dors pas bien depuis une semaine
je ne dors pas donnez-moi quelque chose
pour le sommeil c'est classique en fait
si vous lui donnez quelque chose pour le
sommeil sans voir si à cette période
elle est stressée est-ce qu'elle a eu un
événement particulier est-ce que elle
dort mal parce que le soir elle a un
repas qui est beaucoup trop beaucoup
trop important en termes de quantité
qu'il alourdit qu'il empêche de dormir
il y a une multitude
multitude de facteurs qui qui vous peut
vous empêcher de dormir donc vos
pharmaciennes vous essayez de savoir un
peu ce qui a complètement passé avant de
prescrire complètement et puis peut-être
justement de lui donner certains
conseils effectivement si elle passe
deux heures devant l'ordinateur avant de
se mettre au lit c'est peut-être pas les
meilleures conditions qui soient pour
dormir voyez-vous donc au delà du
Conseil complément alimentaire il y a
une hygiène de vie à respecter pour se
mettre dans les meilleures conditions du
sommeil mais ce que vous dites c'est que
si on a une alimentation équilibrée il
n'y a pas nécessairement besoin dans
consommer non en fait mais en fait vous
savez sur un bout les gens parfois mais
nous sommes quand même tous soin d'une
alimentation très équilibrée parce qu'on
le sait naturellement vous mangez ce que
vous aimez donc donc forcément les cinq
fruits et légumes par jour je même si
c'est une recommandation et je la trouve
tout à fait pertinente c'est vrai que je
ne sais pas qui consomme aujourd'hui 5
fruits et légumes par jour donc
effectivement on voit d'ailleurs qu'il y
a une augmentation très importante de la
consommation des compléments
alimentaires au moment de l'hiver parce
que beaucoup de personnes vont aller
chercher justement un complément en
vitamine C etc pour stimuler un petit
peu l'immunité et faire en sorte que
vous résistiez mieux à la grippe ou aux
affections il y a aussi de nouvelles
tendances parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
végétariens maintenant de végétaliens de
flexitariens est-ce que c'est nouveau
régime ou habitude alimentaire en tout
cas elle elles encouragent l'achat de
compléments parce que justement on fait
l'impasse peut-être sur certains
aliments je sais pas quel l'encourage
c'est qu'elle leur en indispensable ah
oui indice parce que lorsque vous êtes
végétalien ça veut dire que vous ne
mangez rien de carnet et en fait vous
êtes forcément carence de B12 puisque la
B12 la vitamine B12 elle se trouve dans
tout ce qui est alimentation animale
donc on ne peut pas la retrouver dans
aucun autre aliment ne peut compléter
ils font forcément des supplémentations
en vitamine B12 quelqu'un qui ne mange
pas de poisson par exemple il sera
forcément carrossé en acides gras
insaturés et donc il va compenser avec
des oméga-3 etc vous avez certains
régimes effectivement qui vous
prédisposent à l'utilisation de
compléments alimentaires parce que là
vous générez pour le coup des carences
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que ce
vocable complément alimentaire est prêt
à confusion parce que moi quand j'ai
découvert sujet pour moi complément
alimentaire comme il y a le mot
alimentaire c'était forcément des
aliments or c'est pas forcément des
aliments ce qu'il faudrait pas l'appeler
autrement
on a forcément l'impression que c'est un
complément qui complète l'alimentation
mais qui est fait avec des ingrédients
et des aliments oui mais moi je trouve
qu'il porte c'est quand même bien son
nom complément alimentaire ça veut dire
qu'il est là pour venir compléter une
alimentation qui peut être carencé
mais qui pas forcément fait avec des
aliments naturels
ne veut pas dire certes il y a beaucoup
de compléments alimentaires à base de
plantes il y en a beaucoup à base de
vitamines et minéraux il y en a d'autres
qui sont à base de subtilité et vous
vous en vendez en spray ou comme on a pu
le voir là il y a des innovations
maintenant oui mais pourquoi pas enfin
on voit on a des formes galéniques qui
sont extrêmement différentes et
celles-ci est une forme innovante et on
sait très bien que tout ce qui est
absorbé par la muqueuse subblingale
c'est quelque chose qui passe beaucoup
plus vite dans la circulation sanguine
et qui est efficace plus rapidement et
c'est peut-être plus facile à prendre
aussi parce qu'en fait si vous faites
une cure si vous la prenez pas en entier
ça sert à rien j'imagine bah oui enfin
comme tout traitement si même si ça
n'est pas un médicament il faut quand
même ça se tringle à le prendre de façon
régulière bien sûr et c'est vrai que le
fait d'avoir un stress est aussi
pratique pour des personnes qui sont la
vie active qui ont pas forcément l'eau
etc à proximité qui peut pulvériser sous
la langue pourquoi pas il y a des formes
multiples en fait au niveau des
compléments alimentaires et c'est vrai
comme c'est un marché qui est
extrêmement dynamique et bien on voit
énormément d'innovations
on va revenir au début de cette émission
parce qu'on va parler du loup à présent
que vous avez déjà traqué dans votre
circonscription LCP vous avez suivi à
l'époque il empoisonne la vie des
éleveurs alors on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le plat
oui Brigitte alors que le plan d'action
sur le loup à élaboré en 2018 doit
s'acheter en 2023 les éleveurs attendent
beaucoup de la nouvelle mouture qui doit
entrer en vigueur en 2024 car vivre au
contact des cervidés en liberté et pour
eux et pour leur bête une source
permanente d'angoisse c'est un reportage
en Lozère de Maïté Frémont et de Raphaël
lizambard
[Musique]
les photos des
à chaque photo qui défile le souvenir
douloureux du passage du loup le blessé
qui était tout à moitié égorgé
cette nuit du 8 novembre rémi a subi la
pirate de Lozère sur son troupeau de 80
brebis 22 sont tués toutes pleines à
mettre bas une attaque traumatisante
pour les survivants
sans soulever tellement gale été fatigué
de courir dans tous les coins et après
elles avaient peur elles avaient peur
elles avaient peur pour la perte de ses
bêtes Rémi sera indemnisé à hauteur de
5000 euros par l'État
sur notre région et une première année
catastrophique parce que tous nos
voisins ils sont passés donc c'est
arrivé en fin d'été si ça arrive en
début de l'été on a plus de brebis à la
fin de l'été
ça va être impossible à gérer en Lozère
département classé au patrimoine mondial
pour son pastoralisme ces élevages en
pleine nature
266 animaux ont été tués par le loup
contre 70 seulement il y a 3 ans se
défenseur de la nature est un amoureux
du loup mais même lui reconnaît les
dommages causés par le prédateur
trouble la lactation donc il y a des
laitières pour les fromages tels que le
renfort qui et puis les problèmes de
croissance des animaux et problèmes de
patrimoine génétique au sein du troupeau
on prenait bien que si le loup a décimé
les brebis qui détiennent le meilleur
patrimoine du troupeau ça pose un
problème l'ombre du loup plane et
angoisse les éleveurs ce matin-là une
centaine d'entre eux se réunit pour
faire un bilan de l'année dans
l'assemblée un éleveur sur cinq a subi
une attaque l'année dernière leur
président tente de les rassurer
la filière elle fonctionne elle ne sert
pas elle tient le choc au moment où
l'élevage au vin français a perdu 40 %
sa production en 20 ans 40% de sa
production à 20 ans et ben nous notre
filière elle tient le coup cette filière
a obtenu le label
IGP indication géographique protégée
pour ses 12500 agneaux élevés en plein
air une viande reconnue pour son goût ça
lui donne une qualité que les plus
grands bouchés restaurants reconnaissent
notamment les Parisiens puisque notre
production a été évacuée encore à
hauteur de 65% environ sur Paris bah
c'est historique de la filière comme ces
éleveurs 15% de la population active de
l'agriculture en Lozère un dossier
essentiel pour le préfet du département
donc la prédation est de ce niveau là
elle est très très dure à supporter mais
elle reste je dirais regarde du nombre
de moutons sur le territoire elle reste
économiquement et globalement
supportable mais si ça devait encore
empirer ça serait ça deviendrait
économiquement totalement insupportable
des solutions trouvées seraient
d'abattre davantage le prédateur
aujourd'hui 174 loups peuvent être tués
chaque année un quota fixé par l'état
car le loup est classé espèce
strictement protégée au niveau national
européen et international selon un
dernier comptage près de 1000 loups
seraient sur le territoire français
alors avant de parler de tuer des loups
moi j'ai trouvé un chiffre dans la
presse 12000 brebis tués en 2020 il y en
avait 5007 en 2012 lors de 3700 attaques
alors que comptait à l'époque 6200 ou
est-ce que Josiane Corneloup vous avez
des chiffres pour 2021 voire 2022 alors
que maintenant il y a près de 1000 loups
sur le territoire français et bien en
fait effectivement la problématique du
loup elle est elle intéresse 52
départements aujourd'hui il y a 52
départements 2022 qui ont subi une
prédation
c'est vous dire que petit à petit et
bien il colonise tout le territoire
national est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y
a plus de 12000 brebis qui ont été tués
en 2021 ou 2022 où vous n'avez pas les
chips parce qu'ils n'ont pas été encore
communiqués
bien évidemment qui tue et d'ailleurs
nous dans l'hémicycle dans le cadre des
questions au Gouvernement la question du
loup revient très fréquemment parce que
de plus en plus de départements sont
concernés effectivement par cette
prédation et les les dégâts que le
glucose sur les éleveurs sur toute la
filière sont vraiment oui je vous en
parle les éleveurs
c'est un sujet qui revient fréquemment
nous avons vécu des attaques très
importantes
nous n'avions jamais eu connaissance du
loup précédemment
en fait parce que ça fait quand même
plusieurs années maintenant que le louer
est revenu et bien en fait c'était 21 30
faire le reportage et en fait nous avons
eu 146 brebis qui ont été égorgés et
je ne veux pas minimiser ce qui se passe
ailleurs et j'entends la Lozère
également qui est concernée mais chez
nous c'est absolument dramatique parce
que la filière Vienne est une filière
qui s'était très bien redressée qui a
beaucoup investi en terme génétique qui
aujourd'hui nous avons un organisme de
sélection mouton charolais qui est un
bouton de grande qualité qui répond en
termes de viande à de
des souhaits très importants notamment
d'acheteurs étrangers et ces dix années
de recherche génétique si vous voulez
lorsqu'une brebis est égorgée et bien
tout cela est complètement anéanti
on a vu la détresse la filière par terre
il faut pas exagérer non plus de jeunes
éleveurs au vin qui m'ont dit
s'interroger si effectivement le loup
perdu sur la possibilité de poursuivre
et j'ai même des jeunes qui m'ont dit
finalement on s'installera pas mais il y
a des solutions qui existent non alors
il y a 174 loups qui peuvent être tués
par an après ce que j'ai compris c'est
la Commission européenne qui le dit
vous vous pensez qu'il faudrait
augmenter ce quota là par exemple il
faudrait autoriser puisqu'il y a plus de
loups qui seront pour plus vite
est-ce qu'il faudrait augmenter ce
quotas est-ce que ça se négocie ça à
Bruxelles déjà la vraie problématique
c'est de s'interroger le lorsque le Plan
National loue a été écrit il ne faisait
pas état des zones d'élevage c'est la
première fois qu'on voit le loup arriver
dans des zones d'élevage
et très honnêtement pour l'avoir vécu
pour avoir
été aux côtés des agriculteurs des ovins
des agriculteurs ovins pendant ces
attaques il faut vraiment s'interroger
si l'élevage ovins est compatible avec
le loup je ne le pense pas je ne le
pense pas et en particulier dans le
territoire pourquoi nous avons un bocage
particulier qui est très parcellisé avec
beaucoup de petites parcelles or
lorsqu'ils sont pas fermés enfin qui ont
qu'on peut pas grillager alors la
recommandation c'est effectivement de
protéger les parcelles avec des filets
sauf que ça demande un temps
considérable pour poser ses filets
puisqu'en fait que vous avez énormément
de petites parcelles donc c'est pas
comme lorsque vous avez un grand champ
il faut toutes les protéger ça coûte
cher ça c'est un investissement en temps
et puis en plus nous l'avons vu ça
n'empêche pas le loup de sauter dans les
parcelles pour attaquer les troupes donc
c'est quoi ça veut dire qu'en fait on
arrête l'élevage en plein air et on les
met à l'intérieur et bien les protéger
ça a été une vraie problématique si vous
voulez et ça a été une source de stress
et d'angoisse terrible pour les éleveurs
ovins c'était toutes les nuits je veille
puisque les attaques se font très
souvent la nuit et toute la journée je
travaille il était temps que la
situation voilà qu'on trouve une
solution parce que des bergers pour
protéger la nuit ou avoir des équipes
différentes enfin ça coûte plus cher
c'est ça c'est nous on a des parcelles
qui sont disséminés donc c'est très
compliqué
la Patou qui sont
vrai que nous ça n'était pas des
pratiques dans le territoire
et en fait ce que je pense c'est
qu'effectivement le loup est très
incompatible pour moi avec avec des
zones d'élevage comme les nôtres et il
faut forcément réguler davantage le loup
puisque nous étions sur un nombre de
loots de 590 loups moi je fais partie du
groupe national loup nous avons demandé
un recomptage de ces loups aujourd'hui
le chiffre qui ressortit c'est plus de
1000 donc déjà le chiffre était erroné
et lorsque vous savez que nous avons le
droit de prélever 17% avec une petite
marge de plus ou moins 2% donc on peut
aller jusqu'à
19%, si vous prélevez bien évidemment
19% de 500 loups c'est pas la même chose
que si vous prélevez 19% de 1000 loups
donc oui il faut réguler davantage le
long c'est le terme bien gentil pour
dire
donc évidemment il faut il faut sauf que
c'est une espèce strictement protégée
sauf que c'est une espèce strictement
protégée c'est bien là toute la
problématique mais il se trouve que même
si vous avez certainement entendu dire
qu'en Italie ça se passe citoyens et
qu'en Espagne
en Italie
ça se passe mieux voilà et mais c'est
faux nous avons fait une réunion avec
des représentants de plusieurs pays
d'Europe et il y a peu de temps et en
fait et bien les Italiens vous disent
que non ça se passe pas bien il y a un
braconnage qui s'est installé et
finalement 300 ou 400 loups
disparaissent chaque année voilà et en
Espagne notamment dans l'ouest de
l'Espagne où il y avait énormément de
loups puisque sont à plus de 3000 loups
et ils ont autorisé des battus
administratives qui ont très bien
fonctionné et ensuite la population a
demandé débattu sur tout le territoire
national et donc il s'extraitent de la
législation européenne c'est ça et en
fait chacun on pourrait le faire aussi
en France oui on pourrait le faire on
pourrait le faire donc ça c'est se
décide c'est quoi faut donner plus de
pouvoir
enlever les quotas de loups
et ça vous avez été refusé ouais pour
quelle raison alors pour protéger la
situation c'était les premières attaques
donc si vous voulez je pense qu'il faut
que la stabilité pas grave ici voilà et
pour l'instant vous trouvez qu'elle
empire donc vous allez le redemander non
nous avons moi je j'ai rencontré le
ministre d'agriculture Marc fenou qui
est bien conscient effectivement qu'il
faut faire quelque chose parce que je
pense que ce sont des remontées de
territoire qu'il a régulièrement et j'ai
alerté également les députés européens
sur cette fameuse convention de Berne
pour que nous puissions passer d'une
espèce strictement protégée à une espèce
protégée au regard du nombre de loups
aujourd'hui sur le territoire européen
et ce qui permettrait effectivement
d'avoir une régulation beaucoup plus
importante le problème c'est que ben il
faut que ce soit
signé par les 27 pays de l'Union
européenne ce qui n'est pas simple il
faut un accord
l'unanimité j'ai entendu dire que les
chiens errants tuaient autant de brebis
que les loups est-ce que ça c'est vrai
et si c'est vrai on fait pas tout un
plat des chiens errants alors qu'on fait
il y a pas un fantasme du goût quand
même dans nos campagnes effectivement
vous avez raison il y a des attaques qui
relèvent de chiens errants sauf que dès
que vous avez une attaque il y a une
enquête qui est conduite pour déterminer
si effectivement c'est un loup c'est un
chien errant parce que au niveau des des
formes d'attaque ça n'est pas la même
chose
il y a pas de législation c'est ça c'est
plus facile ah bah oui ça n'a rien à
voir avec un loup traumatisé par la
chèvre de Monsieur Seguin
il faut vraiment il faut vraiment
s'inquiéter sur sur cette législation
par rapport au loup parce que ça porte
vraiment préjudice bien sûr à toute la
filière mais particulièrement aux
éleveurs et ça les met en situation de
stress qui je trouve est vraiment
gravissime c'est dit allez on va passer
au dessert à présent et c'est le péché
mignon
et la transition n'est pas facile
Brigitte du lourd au sucré avec une
crêpe flambée au Grand Marnier assez un
totem du patrimoine culinaire français
au point que certains chefs il y a d'os
le nom de Suzette crêpes Suzette comme
le grand Auguste Escoffier qui
revendique la paternité de cette recette
après avoir ajouté de la mandarine et du
Curaçao alors que d'autres cuisiniers
estiment que pour mériter cet
appellation il suffit de la faire
revenir dans le beurre vous voyez il y a
un match il y a un duel alors crêpes
Suzette ou pas la crêpe flambée Brigitte
crêpes Suzette
pour vous ou pas crêpes Suzette ça fait
pas l'unanimité chez les cuisiniers
c'est ce que je voulais dire mais moi je
l'aime bien évidemment avec une petite
dose d'alcool parce que comme je vous le
disais j'aime bien la cuisine qui a du
caractère et j'aime bien voilà le petit
goût relevé du fait de l'alcool mais moi
j'aime bien l'avoir flambée
parce que je trouve c'est tout le
panache du flambage et il y a tout un
spectacle en fait toute une mise en
scène aussi et j'aime beaucoup voilà
j'aime beaucoup c'est quoi c'est des
souvenirs d'enfance aussi de crêpes
flambée
non pas du tout le plat magnifique le
partage aussi et puis c'est vrai que
voilà l'enfance qui n'a pas mangé des
crêpes dans son enfance au petit
déjeuner ou goûter et pour les
conditions de sécurité on ne pouvait pas
mettre le feu à l'Assemblée ici ça
aurait pu être utilisé par des biens
politiques donc on les a fait flambées
en coulisses
flambée au Grand Marnier qui est donc
cette liqueur d'orange à base de à base
de Cognac que vous affectionnez
particulièrement oui j'avais dit j'avais
dit Grand Marnier ou marre de Bourgogne
parce que oui ce sont des alcools qui
vont très bien avec avec la crêpe et je
trouve qu'encore une fois voilà le marc
de Bourgogne aussi
chez Françoise que le Grand Marnier
peut-être mais
c'est vrai que il y a beaucoup de
marques de Bourgogne également dans ma
région bien évidemment et le fait qu'il
soit vous savez vieilli en fût de chêne
ça donne aussi un arôme particulier un
petit peu plus fort que le Grand Marnier
parce qu'on sent quand même beaucoup
Laurent et le curaçao évidemment mais
j'aime beaucoup les deux ouais et vous
faites la pâte à crêpes souvent vous en
préparez ah oui bien sûr alors vous la
laissez reposer ou pas parce qu'il y a
pas mal aussi
mettez de la bière non pas de bière
de l'eau pétillant
donc elles sont très légères et elles
sont très vous savez ce sont vraiment
les crêpes dentelles très fine très fine
c'est meilleur que la farine de la
farine normale moi j'aime bien
et elles sont plus oui elles sont plus
plus transparents voyez plus aéré
on mangeait plus c'est ça
en tous les cas merci on regroupe la
crêpe suzette c'est un peu désuet comme
dessert mais c'est très bon c'est très
bon
alors on finit cette émission en musique
pendant que vous dégustez cette cette
crêpe flambée au Grand Marnier on va
écouter ce ce morceau que vous avez
choisi et vous allez nous dire pourquoi
juste après
[Musique]
c'est le clair de lune de Debussy c'est
une de vos de vos morceaux à un de vos
morceaux préférés
alors si j'ai choisi ce morceau clair de
lune de Debussy d'abord c'est un morceau
extrêmement connu un certain moment
l'oeuvre la plus célèbre de Debussy mais
c'est surtout parce que dans ma
circonscription
Juliana stanbach qui interprète ce
morceau ce morceau
a souhaité créer un festival
il y a maintenant 19 ans que ce festival
a été créé
elle a amené de la musique classique en
milieu rural
je suis très attachée à l'offre
culturelle en meilleure rurale et je
trouve que c'était un vrai défi parce
que lorsqu'on parle culture on pense
souvent aux grandes salles etc et
Juliana stanbarque il a directrice de ce
festival qui a lieu la première semaine
d'août chaque année à souhaiter associer
musique classique et patrimoine et vous
savez que en Charolais Brionnais nous
avons un patrimoine roman extraordinaire
et donc les concerts se passent dans les
petites églises romanes dans les petites
chapelles etc
donc je trouve que c'est une magnifique
initiative tant
pique musical humaine en plus elle a
un vrai une vraie connaissance de
différents artistes musiciens donc elle
fait venir des musiciens internationaux
pas moins souvent de 11 ou 12
et au début le démarrage de festival a
été difficile puisque vous ne vous
adressez à une à une clientèle qui est
pas forcément initiée à la musique
classique la démocratise aussi beaucoup
la démocratise beaucoup la musique
classique et ça aujourd'hui le festival
fait sale conbe à chaque fois pendant la
période covid ils ont même maintenu le
festival avec toutes les contraintes en
termes de nombres et ils ont multiplié
les concerts de façon à avoir une jauge
c'est ça et c'est dans votre
circonscription merci beaucoup je tienne
d'abord accepté notre invitation merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LCP merci beaucoup
[Musique]